okay so it's in the 1920s it's after the
world after world war one Russia is in
pretty bad shape the villages are full
of brutalized men who have
post-traumatic stress disorder and lots
of people who are not doing well at all
and the bloody intellectuals come into
the town and they say you know those
successful farmers up the street that
you've always been pretty jealous about
in your useless manner well there are
actually pigs and demons who are
stealing from you so why don't you come
out we'll form a nice little mob and
we'll take everything they've got and
that's exactly what happened and all
those people were killed or raped or set
off to Siberia in the middle of the
bloody winter where there wasn't even
anything for them to to anywhere for
them to live or anything for them to eat
so they all died and then the
consequence of that was a few years
later six million people starved to
death in the Ukraine and Malcolm
Muggeridge had been reporting on that
since the 1930s and so that was the that
was the first wind really that the West
God of exactly what was happening in the
Soviet Union but even at that point the
bloody left-wing intellectuals in North
America were so damn clueless and in
Europe that they never paid much
attention to it with the exception of
certain number of people like George
Orwell who wrote 1984 and an animal farm
which is of course a discussion the main
pig in Animal Farm is Stalin of course
and it's a story ella gory about the
Russian Revolution whose basic motif is
we're all equal but of course some all
animals are equal but some are more
equal than others and that's the motif
that's the motif of Animal Farm so there
have been warnings all the way through
right from the beginning of the Russian
Revolution to the west about exactly
what was going on but because communist
and Marxist ideology is very good at
addling the the weak minds of idiot
intellectuals there was a huge section
of the population who was fomenting I
suppose against the standard what would
you call it political psychological and
social order who were work absolutely
committed to you know the ethic that's
encased in statements like from each
according to his ability to each
according to his need which sounds
perfectly wonderful if you think about
it for about 15 seconds but if you think
about it for six months becomes
unbelievably murderer
and its reach and and and intent and so
anyways the French for whatever reasons
seem to be particularly opaque to reason
I'll give an example so the doctrine of
Pol Pot in Cambodia that also killed
about six million people hidden so what
they did in Cambodia once the revolution
occurred was decide that everyone in the
city were parasites on the countryside
because the countryside full of farmers
was where the primary production was
taking place and they regarded the city
dwellers as parasites on that
fundamental production so they basically
emptied out the cities and sent all the
people in the cities out to work in the
country as forced labor and six million
people died there and the chief
architect of that bloody project got his
PhD from the Sorbonne and said exactly
what he was going to do when he went
back to Cambodia was cheered along by
the French intellectuals who thought
that that was just a fine idea so that's
all background for why I don't think any
of you guys really know much about 20th
century history so anyways what happened
in the 1970s when when Solzhenitsyn
published the Gulag Archipelago was that
it was so brilliant the book and so
overwhelming in its emotional and
intellectual and historical power that
it became impossible for anyone to
continue to claim that Marxism /
communism had any intellectual or
ethical integrity whatsoever it was done
it was done and that's part of the
reason why he won the Nobel Prize and
part of the reason by the way why the
Soviet Union collapsed because once word
got out about exactly what was actually
going on there was no way of making a
coherent argument in favor of say
exporting the workers revolution around
the world it's like the consequence of
that was well documented by Solzhenitsyn
season the Western intellectuals tried
to make excuses for what had happened in
the Soviet Union by blaming it on
Stalin's cult of personality perversion
of the original accurate Marxist
doctrine so they basically said well
Lenin had Lenin lived because he died
quite young and was replaced by stell
and hadlen and lived the promised utopia
would have been delivered but so
Nansen being an absolute genius
documented the relationship number one
between the axioms of Marxist and
communist thought and the laws that were
generated primarily by Lenin and the and
the construction of these camps and the
dekulakization and all the mass murders
he documented the causal relationship
between them and laid them clearly at
the feet not of Stalin but of Lenin and
so that was also a major blow because it
undermined the remaining argument of the
left-wing radical left-wing apologists
in in in the West for the for the
viability of Marxist / communist
doctrines and you still hear people
today many people when they're faced
with the you know if they're if they're
if they're Marxist in their orientation
and they're faced with the data
pertaining to what happened in the
Soviet Union they'll say something like
well that wasn't real Marxism but one of
the things that you might answer to that
is well fine except that in every bloody
country in the world where that doctrine
was implemented regardless of the wide
cultural differences between the
cultures say the Soviet Union China
Cambodia and so forth exactly the same
thing happened every time and we still
have a great example of that today in
the form of North Korea I don't know if
you've ever looked at a map of the world
at night you know you can get a map of
the entire globe at night you look at
South Korea it's lit up like jewels it's
nothing but light like the east coast of
the United States and Canada and North
Korea is dark and the reason for that is
that 50 60 years of barbaric communist
despotic rule means the country that's
completely an industrialized where every
single person is malnourished or
starving to death where everyone lives
in terror all the time and where there's
nothing but the continual production of
labor in labor camps just like in the
Soviet Union and Maoist China so if we
were willing to pay attention we could
still see examples of that today and
that's not an anomaly North Korea is
exactly what you'd expect given the
doctors upon which it's founded